wenn du lust hast hühner zu halten dann
bist du hier genau richtig ich werde in
diesem video nämlich erklären die
hühnerhaltung funktioniert also vom
stall über die richtigen rassen den
ausläuft die fütterungen alles was man
als anfänger wissen muss wenn man mit
dem gedanken spielt sich wieder an zu
schaffen wirst nämlich ein richtig
toller plan ich liebe unsere hühner ich
bin eine richtige verrückte kleine
hühner
falls du meinen kanal noch nicht kennst
hier spreche ich über die
selbstversorgung aus dem eigenen garten
ihr könnt gerne ein abo da lassen wenn
euch das interessiert dann bekommt ihr
eine benachrichtigung sobald ein neues
video erscheint ja sprechen wir erst mal
über die hühnerrassen die es so gibt hat
man erst mal so eine grundlegende
entscheidung zwischen zwei typen von
hühnern zu treffen das ist einmal die
turbo hühner die auch in der
landwirtschaft gehalten werden egal ob
ökologisch oder nicht ökologischer
werden oft diese braunen oder weißem
turbo hühner gehalten die fast jeden tag
ein ei legen allerdings nur eine kurze
zeit lang danach sind die total
ausgepowert und werden auch in der
landwirtschaft dann nach einem jahr oder
spätestens 16 monaten auch durch jüngere
ersetzt
dem gegenüber stehen die alten rassen
die robusten rassen die vielleicht nicht
ganz so reinhauen dass die
eierproduktion angeht da wir über einen
längeren zeitraum produzieren die man da
nicht nach einem jahr schon schlachten
muss bzw
ging ich nach einem jahr schon aufhören
zu legen weil gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche rassen ich bin ein
absoluter fan davon alte rassen zu
halten auch bedrohte rassen zu halten
weil ich es super wertvoll finde diese
rassen zu erhalten weil die immer mehr
an bedeutung verlieren es gibt ganz
viele alte tollen hühnerrassen die vom
aussterben bedroht sind weil sie in der
landwirtschaft einfach keinen bestand
mehr haben dadurch das ja immer ein
ziemlicher profit druck herrscht und ja
viele landwirte daneben auch gezogen
sind diese tour behindert zu halten auch
wenn diese alten tollen lassen
eigentlich robuster sind und es einfach
super schade wäre wenn die in
vergessenheit geraten oder ganz verloren
gehen aber bevor ich euch jetzt erzähle
was wir affen sind wie ich euch
empfehlen würde oder die wir halten und
die wir super toll finden möchte ich
noch mal auch so ein paar typen eingehen
wie es bei hühnern gibt es gibt die
reihen
legehennen typen also die rassen die vor
allem auf eier produktionen gezüchtet
wurden
dann gibt es fleisch schüler über die
eier leistung hängt sich überhaupt keine
rolle spielt die einfach nur möglichst
schnell möglichst dick werden wollen ich
denke mal dass alle die dieses video
hier schauen hühner der eier wegen
halten wollen und nicht masthähnchen
halten wollen dass ich geht es einfach
um legehennen- aber es gibt eben einen
zwischen typ das ist dass zwei nutzungs
huhn das ist super toll für
selbstversorger die vielleicht auch mal
einen hut schlachten wollen und trotzdem
viele eier haben wollen wir halten
verschiedene zwei nutzungsraten die
stelle ich euch auch gleich noch mal vor
der vorteil von ihnen ist das wenn man
mal eine henne prüfen lassen möchte und
also einer eigenen küchen züchten möchte
dass man dann ja immer 50 prozent helden
und 50 prozent hat und man kann nicht
alle hähne behalten rallye je händen
bedränge würden und auch untereinander
kämpfen
deswegen ist nun immer gezwungen die hen
entweder bewusst zu werden aber es gibt
jene als leute wollen deswegen ist es
sehr schwierig oder die daneben zuschlag
nun das ist 22 nutzungs raschen
natürlich toll ist die hände dann auch
ordentlich fleisch und setzen sie was
sich das dann auch lohnt viele von euch
wissen ja wahrscheinlich dass die
männlichen küken bei legehennen sich
dann direkt nach dem schlupf getötet
werden damit geguckt wenn ich als
männlich weiblich und die männchen
werden vergast geschreddert oder
irgendwie anders umgebracht das ist
einfach super schade ist ein kampf
brutal und bei zwei nutzungsraten kann
man den männchen daneben noch ein
längeres leben bescheren und dann auch
etwas davon haben ich mein sohn
geschreddert das küken das kann man
vielleicht noch als kunde futter zu
arbeiten oder irgendwelchen falken an
verkaufen aber das ist doch einfach
super schade dass dafür ein tier sterben
muss aber jeweils sicher ein paar
konkrete rasse tipps deswegen habe ich
euch mal vier schüler raschen ausgesucht
die ich absolut super finde zwei davon
nämlich auch zwei nutzung straßen das
ist einmal das vorwerk und das ist auch
eine vom aussterben bedrohte rasse ein
tolles zwei nutzung screen er so ein
bisschen kleiner superschwer sind die
nicht und legen auch sehr gut also eher
eine betonte zwei nutzung des rasse dann
gibt's marians die sind deutlich größer
für mehr auf zwei stück ist die liebe
ich heiß und innig die legen nämlich
supertolle dunkelrote ja ja die sind
unglaublich toll ich versuche ich meinen
foto einzublenden er so auch mit ganz
tolle rasse auch eine sehr schwere und
ruhige rasse die hauen auch nicht so oft
ab je schwerer die hühner sind desto
schwerfälliger sind sie auch und desto
entspannter und dann kommen die nicht
mehr so leicht über die zäune drüber und
dann ist eine ganz tolle raste finde ich
auch ganz begeistert bin
das schwedische blumen huhn davon haben
wir leider nur eins aber das ist schon
beides ist auch super hübsch ist klar
das liegt super viele eier dass ich eine
unserer besten legehennen und dies so
süß und so hübsch schicken und die
vierte phase die ich euch vorstellen
möchte ist auch eine schwedische rasse
die heißen schwedische ist es sind
grünleger dass die legen für kies
farbene eier davon haben wir gerade zwei
jungen mal schauen wenn die anfangen zu
legen da freue ich mich auf jeden fall
schon sehr darauf sie sollen auch sehr
sehr fleißige legeren sein und das ist
auch eine ganz super tolle super hübsche
hühnerrasse ist ihr könnt mir ja mal
verraten was eure lieblings rassen sind
falls da draußen jemand zuschaut da
schon hühner hat dann schreib mir das
gerne mal in die kommentare da könnt ihr
auch den anderen da noch was der
empfehlungen geben und wenn ihr euch
schon für viele rassen entschieden hat
die erhalten möchte dann schreibt das
auch gerne mal rein ich bin das immer
ganz inspirieren ich ja auch eine lange
liste mit lauter hühnerrassen die ich
irgendwann auch noch unbedingt haben
will aber wir haben eben nur platz für
800 ist das eigentlich nicht wehren
kann eine frage die ich auch immer
wieder gestellt bekommen braucht man
einen haaren wenn man hühner halten
möchte nein braucht man erstmal nicht
das ist ganz netten haben zu haben wir
haben keine an weil wir einen sehr
kleinen stall haben und gegen womit
eierlegenden tieren hilfen sollten aber
wenn ich irgendwann mal die kapazitäten
habe wird auf jeden fall ein haaren bei
uns einzigen euch das auch die partei
für die verteidigung auch ihre ladies
und wenn ich lust unsere nachbarn nahmen
ihre helme und ich beobachte da immer
wieder dass sie auch sehr zuvorkommend
sind denen sie dann gegenüber wenn die
irgendwas leckeres finden dann rufen die
idee die bringen den auch teilweise
futter und legen das ding vor dinara
sind ja auf jeden fall ist hänge zu
halten
die sache ist ich kenne sind laut muss
man überlegen ob es nun der
nachbarschaft geht und wenn man gucken
weiter vermehren möchte von den eigenen
hühnern dann braucht man natürlich auch
den hahn der die eier befruchtet aber an
sich legen die hühner auf wenn kein hahn
dabei ist und sie sind auch glaube ich
relativ zufrieden also ich habe nicht
das gefühl dass unsere hühner die
männliche gesellschaft vermisst müssen
ja kommen wir zum zu einem wichtigen
thema dem hühnerstall wie groß muss denn
so einen hühnerstall seien eigentlich
gar nicht mal so ist weil die schöne
aber wenn sie genug auslauf haben den
stall nur zum übernachten brauchen
und da passt ein relativ viele hühner
dicht an dicht
solange sie den tag über draußen sein
können die sind auch bei regen draußen
sind es meistens und auch bei schnee
macht ihn überhaupt nicht aus deswegen
kann man pro drei hühner und es für
einen quadratmeter schneefläche
einplanen das ist auch ganz wichtig dass
sie auf der sitzstange genug platz haben
da braucht sondern ungefähr 20 bis 30
zentimeter platz auf der sitzstange die
übernachten ja immer auch noch stange
die etwas höher auf die hängt sein
sollte so dass sich da sicher fühlen wir
haben schon ganz schön pfiffig ist auch
wenn ich abends zum steige und die tür
zu machen will sie dann anfangen um rück
zu werden weil sie denken ich werden
raubtier und die finden sich viel
sicherer wenn sie oben auf eine stange
listen können so als würden die im baum
sitzen mitteln sowie vorausgehen
geschützt zu sein also 20 bis 30 cm
platz auf der stange
und dann braucht man natürlich auch noch
nest boxen da denken wir immer viele
leute wo ich muss sich jede hohen eine
eigene nest box zur verfügung stellen
das muss man nicht also die zeit
sehen sich sowieso die nächst boxen und
wenn man viele netbooks hatte ich habe
schon oft auf dem bauernhof das erlebt
dass die hühner dann trotzdem alle in
ein oder zwei boxen legen und die
anderen komplett ignorieren und einfach
nur ihre lieblingsplätze aufsuchen oder
so kann man ungefähr einklagen dass man
vor fünf hühner oder profi hühner und
für einen s box zur verfügung stellen
sollte es ist super wichtig dass der
steile sicher ist vor raubtieren weil es
gibt alle möglichen raubtiere die euro
wieder aufessen wollen zum beispiel
füchse marder oder auch raubvögel die
sind eher im gehege ein problem und
deswegen soll der stall so dick sein
sondern soll ihn ja auch abends zu
machen und morgens wieder aufmachen so
dass da keine tiere reinkommen können
und der staat muss so dick sein dass an
keiner stelle ein ei durch passt weil wo
ein ei durch passt da passt auch einmal
dadurch das ist die faustregel als
einstreu eignet sich am allerbesten sand
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht wenn ich
den stein mit sand einstreu das dann
quasi keine gerüche entstehen man kann
dann auch einfach mit seiner chip wird
man auf das cup regionen sauber macht
die den kot brocken raus zu tieren und
dann den sand einfach nur einmal im jahr
austauschen das funktioniert sehr gut
wir machen das im moment nicht mehr weil
wir einen sehr sandigen boden haben und
den hühnermist unserem garten aus
bringen und den boden nicht noch
sandiger machen wollen das läge streuen
wir mit sägespänen das ist auch super
wenig stroh eingestreut hat man oft das
problem dass in den strohhalm eben leben
ich hier können sich darin super gut
versteckten deswegen möchte das nicht so
gerne sondern verbände auch in den
nächst boxen
diese serie späne die nets boxen sollte
man regelmäßig sauber halten damit auch
die eier sauber bleiben damit die
hühnerhof fuß tragen da ihre eier
abzulegen
und wenn ihr probleme habt dass eure
hühner nicht in den nächst boxen legen
und gibt sich so feldmeier die man da
rein legen kann und wenn an einem ort
schon eier liegen dann haben die wieder
in altes bedürfnis da er ja auch noch
dazu zu legen und so kann man denen das
abgewöhnen dass die ja im ganzen garten
verteilt liegen sondern jeden dank
suchen muss bzw fehler ja auch überhaupt
nicht findet
haben sie alles schon erlebt wenn ihr
euch hühner anschaffen möchte dann habe
ich euch eine checkliste erstellt mit
allen sachen die ihr vorbereiten
pc anschaffen misst urlaubsvertretung
muss man vorher organisieren damit man
im moment kann ihn niemand in urlaub
fahren aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass
man das irgendwann wieder kann dann wird
daneben auch klar ist wer sich um die
hühner kümmert sondern nicht da als das
habe ich alles für euch aufgelistet ich
kann euch gerne den link zu der
checkliste unten in die video
beschreibung packen dann könnt ihr euch
die da gerne kostenlos runterladen und
habt so einen fahrplan beziehungsweise
könnt euch sicher sein dass es in das
muss ich vorbereitet haben und dann
können die hühner kommen ist einfach ein
gutes gefühl oder als ich meine ersten
hühner angeschafft hatte da habe ich so
viele fragen gehabt und ich war mir so
unsicher ich wollte auch alles natürlich
perfekt machen weil ich absolut vernarrt
in hinterhalte millionen checkliste auf
jeden fall sehr geholfen
deswegen habe ich die für euch erstellt
wenn ihr euch gerne runterladen da
kommen wir zum auslauf der hat man
verschiedene optionen am schönsten ist
es natürlich wenn die hühner frei
herumlaufen können das kommt natürlich
immer darauf an wo man wohnt ob das
überhaupt möglich ist bei uns gibt es
nicht aber so ein wenig genug platz
hätten sondern vor allem weil die china
sonst unsere gemüsebeete plündern würden
und dass er einfach sehr schade weil die
auch bei den nachbarn randalieren würden
deswegen haben wir einen mobilen auslauf
wenn man kann natürlich auch einen
festen auslauf haben wo die hühner
permanent drin sind ich finde es aber
schöner wenn die immer mal wieder auf
frisches gras kommen deswegen haben wir
einen mobilen weidezaun einen
elektrozaun mit einem mobilen stall den
warum tragen können es gibt auch stelle
mit kleidern unserer hatte auch mal
räder aber die sind leider schon kaputt
die waren nicht so geländetauglich
deswegen tragen wir den jetzt immer
wieso eine sänfte und durch den garten
wenn wir unsere hühner alle paar wochen
umziehen und somit auch der rasen
geschont und nahm immer mal wieder ein
bisschen abwechslung
wir haben am anfang ein netz über unsere
hühner gehege aufgespannt und die frau
auf hügeln zu schützen
das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr weil das
netz immer nach dem regen auf dem boden
hing er ist nicht hingekriegt das so zu
spannen das system funktioniert hätte
deswegen achten wir jetzt darauf dass
wir das mobile gehege immer nur darauf
bauen wo bäume oder sträucher sind so
dass die hühner sich wenn sie einen
raubvogel sehen und die fassen dann
ziemlich gut auf was sie sich darunter
in schutz bringen können sie mit dem
schutznetz das war auch bei der lösung
die wir haben wo wir so oft umziehen mit
den männern
nicht praktikabel weil wir es nicht
überall dieses netz aufspannen konnten
ohne dass wir irgendwelche posten hätten
installieren müssen
und das nach regen oder schnee im boden
hängen das wird leider überhaupt nicht
funktioniert kann euch gerne das
equipment verwenden also die zäune das
elektrogerät den die tränke was auch
immer alles in der video beschreibung
verlinkten wenn ihr danach schauen wollt
was wir da benutzen ja kommen wir zum
futter was soll man den hühnern füttern
wir führt dann ein legehennenfutter das
ist ein bio futter las in deutschland
angebaut wird es uns zwei sachen die mir
super wichtig sind finde gerade wenn man
eigene tiere hält dann ist es ja die
möglichkeit es richtig gut zu machen und
es so zu machen wie man es sich
vorstellt dass eben keinen regenwald
abgeholzt wird das war keine
spritzmittel im futter sind jeder
letztendlich auch auf unserem tisch
landen deswegen das bio futter die
hühner bekommen aber auch alles was bei
uns an riechen abfällen anfällt solange
es nicht zu fettig zu salzig oder süß
ist können die fast alles fressen und
freuen sich da auch immer viel mehr
darüber als gehörtes körnerfutter so
dass sie auch eine sehr
abwechslungsreiche ernährung haben und
wir unsere art stelle in einer
verwandeln können es ist eine super
sache
ich habe so einen topf in der küche
stehen wo immer den tag über alles rein
kommt dass wir so an abfällen haben
sagen wir meine sauer gewordene milch
oder das angetrocknete brot dass ich ein
dampfkessel gefunden habe weil man so
nicht aufgegessen hat erkennt es wenn
ihr kinder haben
das landet alles in dem topf das sieht
immer richtig eklig aus am ende des
tages aber die wiener freuen sich
darüber ist wer das nur minimal schlecht
denn deine hühner frei laufen können
dann können sie sich natürlich auch viel
ihrer nahrung selber suchen es gibt auch
rassen wie leer futter selber sehen als
andere gerade alte rassen die ein
bisschen robuster sind sind auf twitter
und suchen sich sehr viel denn darum
einfach in der natur die fressen auch
viel gras graz kann bis zu 20 prozent
der hühner ernährung ausmachen so kann
man sehr viel futter kosten sparen wenn
man den hühnern einen
abwechslungsreichen auslauf zur
verfügung stellt was wir außerdem machen
ist dass wir mit den hühnern zusammen
kompostieren fest wir lassen unsere
schüler regelmäßig auf den kompost da
können die sich auch super viele
in sachen aus klicken erstmal nach karl
hammer suchen auf youtube das ist so ein
toller typ aus amerika der ich habe 600
hühner nur mit kompost für das die
verwandelnde abfälle gartenabfälle in
kompost und er näher ernährt die darf
und er muss da kein getreide zu füttern
so weit ich das und erinnerung habe weil
die so viel futter auf dem komposthaufen
finden und gleichzeitig den kompost viel
schneller umsetzen als wenn man den
einfach so vor sich hin verrotten lässt
sich ja ganz viel darin scharen und das
alles in bewegung drin dann ist das
natürlich noch sogar richtig dass diese
immer sauberes wasser haben das ist
wirklich wirklich wirklich wichtig damit
die gesund bleiben es gibt viele
probleme die entstehen können wenn man
da nicht drauf achtet ich habe dafür so
eine automatische wasser trinken kann
ich auch gerne verlinken die ist super
praktisch weil das wasser sehr für strom
bleibt die werde ich aber immer auf
einen stein stellen weil er sonst zu
viel isst jahr einsparen und wenn man
das offene stein etwas erhöht aufstellt
dann bleibt das wasser noch viel
frischer
[Musik]
wenn ihr lust habt dass ich noch mehr
videos zur hühnerhaltung mache dann
schreibt man das gerne in die kommentare
gerne auch mit themenvorschlägen
ansonsten findet ihr hier drüben und da
unten noch zwei anleger - die euch
interessieren könnten
ich freue mich wenn ihr da vorbeischaut
wenn euch das video gefallen habt gebt
ihnen den daumen nach oben macht es gut
bis zum nächsten mal